[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه
يظهر امام القضاء الامريكي وتركيزات بانه
لن يواجه الاعداء
تنسيق الامريكي الياباني كوري جنوبي غير
مسبوق لرد موحد على تهديدات كوريا
الشماليه النوويه
الارجنتين بقياده ميسي تواجه شجاعه
كرواتيا ونجمها مدهش في نصف نهائي مونديال
قطر
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا البدايه من الاحتجاجاته
في ايران حيث اعتبرته لها ان اعدام
السلطات الايرانيه المحتجين الايرانيين
المحسن
شكاريضا خطيره وقالت هيوم رئيس
اخرين يواجهون خطر الاعدام وظيفه العمليات
الاعدام هذه لانها انتهاكم الصارخ للعداله
وتصعد خطير للوضع مشيره الى انه من
المتوقع ان تحاكم السلطات الايرانيه عشرات
الاشخاص الاخرين ببينهم اطفال يتهم او قد
يتصل عقوباتهم الى حد الاعدام
من جانبها مشاهدينا حادثه منظمه العفو
الدوليه المجتمع الدولي على اتخاذ كافه
الاجراءات اللازمه للضغط على السلطات
الايرانيه لوقف عمليه الاعدام واعتبرت
منظبته ان الاعدام العملي العلني للشاب في
ايران يفضح نظامها القضائي الذي يستخدمه
النظام كاداه للقمع والانتقام من
المتطهرين الذين شاركوا في الاحتجاجات
الاخيره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
دانه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تنفيذ
النظام الايراني ثاني عمليه اعدام على
ارتباط بحركه احتجاجات وظيفه ان الاعدامات
العلنيه في ايران تظهر ان النظام يخشى
شعبه ويريد ترهيبه
ضد سلطات الايرانيه وتصل حزمه الاولى
بحمله قمع متظاهرين حيث تضم 20 مسؤولا
وكيانا بالاضافه الى مؤسسه الاذاعه
والتلفزيون
الثاني ايضا اربعه مسؤولين من بينهم ثلاثه
جنرالات في الحرس الثوري كما تضم اربعه
كيانات متخصصه في صناعه المسيرات
بعدين يقاشره معمقه وشامله للعلاقات
المتساعده التعقيد مع ايران اكد وزراء
خارجيه دول الاتحاد دعمهم لتطلعات الشعب
الايراني المشروعه نحو الحريه الوزراء
صادقوا على حزمتين من العقوبات الاضافيه
بشان تزويد طيران روسيا بالمسيرات وحمله
المسجد ضد المتظاهرين
حول حمله القمع المنهج ضد المتظاهرين
وتشمل القائمه الاضافيه واحده وعشرين
اثنان وذلك في نطاقه دعم الاتحاد للشعب
الايراني الوزراء الاوروبيون يحذرون ايران
بشده من عواق باي دعم عسكريا اضافيا تقدمه
الى روسيا خاصه الصواريخ البالستيه قصيره
الامديه
ضد الذين يزودون روسيا وسيارات تستخدمها
في قصف اوكرانيا وارتكاب جرائم الحرب هذه
المباحثات الاوروبيه
حيث ابتعدت ايران عن مقتضيات البرنامج
النووي ولم تتخذ القرارات المناسبه للتوسل
الى احياء الدفاع
والعقوبات التي تصدر اليوم
لان احياء الاتفاق النووي مفيد بالنسبه
للجانب الايراني
لا تزعل الحصول على تزود النوويه
الاتحاد الاوروبي عازم على ان لا تتزوج
ايران ابدا بالسلاح النووي ويدعو الدوله
كافه الى تنفيذ القرار الدولي
2231 لعام 2015 وفي ذلك رساله مباشره الى
طهران البيان الاوروبي ورد في ست صفحات
ونصف الصفحات من الرسائل التي تضمنها دعوه
الاتحاد الاوروبي ايران الى التعاوني مع
لجنه تقصي الحقائق الدوليه في العنف
المتواصلي في الداخل الايراني
وتحذير الاتحاد الاوروبي ايران من عواقب
التزويدها روسيا بالصواريخ البالسيه ان هي
فعلت او ستفعل
ويفهموا من سياق البيان الاوروبي ككل نضج
الموقف هنا
واحتمال توجهه الى مجلس الامن اذا استحال
التفاهم مع ايران
ردينا الفريق العربيه
قبل ان تقطع المياه والكهرباء بشكل كامل
والغاز والهاتف عن العائله
[موسيقى]
مشاهد
الايراني
المتكرره تحاول يعني
همم
[موسيقى]
تتحول الى الاحتجاجات ضدها كما حدثت فيها
حالات اشياء المظاهرات في مختلف المحافظات
الايرانيه ايضا تريد ان يدفع العوائل
الثمن من خلال الترهيب والتخويف
لكي لا يستمر بالمطالب بمحاسبه مرتكبي هذه
الجرائم فضلا عن الحديث عن هذه المحاكمات
التي تنتقل الى ادنى شروط المحاكمه العادل
حتى وفق القوانين ايرانيه نفسها هذا ما
تحدث به عدد من المحامين ونشطاع حقوق
الانسان قالوا ان همم محاكمه شخص
بتهمه قتل اثنين من عناصر البسيج بثلاثه
اسابيع فقط ليست هناك اداء واضحه يعني
للمحاكمه المحكمه الثوريه اصلا هي غير
دستوريه الشهود غير معروفين ملثمين همم
يعني حتى محامي لم يتم توكيله من قبل
العائله للمتهم واا الجميع يعلم ان
المحاكم الثوريه في ايران هي شعبه من
الاستخبارات يعني يتم تعيين القوات
والمحامين والهاتف من هناك وبالتالي يكون
همم الحكم الصادر هو تطبيق للسيناريو الذي
ترسمه وفي مقابل لم نجد هذه السرعه في همم
ايجاد او القبض على اي من قطره المتظاهرين
لكن هناك استاذ همم صالح هل هناك مؤشرات
على ان هذه السيره الايرانيه او دعنا نقول
ان هذه الاعدامات هل نجحت وهذه السياسه هل
نجحت في تحجيم هذه التظاهرات هل نجحت هذه
الخطه حتى ان هذه هناك مؤشرات تدل على ذلك
ام على العكس تماما هي ذاته من زخامها لا
راينا يعني من خلال ردود الافعال ان نتائج
كانت عكسيه خروج الناس باستمرار
بالاضرابات همم يعني حتى عندما مثلا تم
تنفيذ هذا الحكم في مشهد همم ضد مجيد رضا
نور خرجت مظاهرات واحتجاجات في محافظات
اخرى همم ايضا ما حدث في همم
اا حالات مشابهه في زائر الاعدامات النظام
في الواقع يحاول يعني بث الخوف وهذه المره
الاولى التي يقول انه اعدم بها هذا المتهم
على الملا ولم يكن على الملا في الواقع
يعني ليس امام الناس لانه يخشى اندلاع
تجمعات لكنه ايضا يهدف الى رفع معنويات
البسيج والحرس الثوري الذي يشاركون في
القمع وقتل العشرات منهم في المواجهات مع
المتظاهرين ويريد ان يقول لهم ان كل من
يتعرض للقوى الامنيه فيتعرض للمحاسبه حتى
لو كان بهذه الطريقه السوريه والانتقاميه
في الواقع والمتظاهرين فهي محاكمات سياسيه
وميدانيه محاكمات التي تعقدها محكمه اكثر
من منها تطبيق القانون والقصاص وما تدعيه
السلطات من انها تريد محاسبه مرتك فكره
شكرا
الايراني صالح حميد اليك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وردنا على سؤالي لمراسله العربيه
لاطلاق سراح جميع السجناء وشيرا في الوقت
نفسه الى ان واشنطن ستستمر في دعم
المحتجين الايرانيين في معركه الكرامه
والحقوق
مثل مثل
باز في الايام القليله الماضيه كما ساحضر
الفرصه مقابله عائله عماد شكري لذا فقط
التعامل بعمق مع العديد من الاشخاص الذين
تاثروا شخصيا باعتقالي افراد عائلاتهم
المحتجزين ظلما بشكل غير قانوني في ايران
وانا ملتزم شخصيا بهذا الامر
للامن القومي اقضي عشرات ان لم يكن مئات
السعاده في العمل على هذه الحالات
للاجتماع مع هذه العائلات وسستمر في ذلك
بينما نمضي قدما احيانا كانت هناك مشكله
تتعلق بالجدول الزمني لكن على مدار العام
الماضي
والمحتجازين في روسيا وافغانستان وفنزويلا
وايران والصين واماكن اخرى ايضا
وساواصل القيامه بذلك
وفيما يتعلق بالسؤال عن ما نفعله فيما
يتعلق بدعم المحتجين في ايران لقد راينا
جمله من الاعلانات المتعلقه بالعقوبات على
اولئك الذين يرتكبون هذه الانتهاكات
الجسيمه الحقوقيه وهذا القمع لم نقوم بذلك
بانفسنا حيث قمنا بالتنسيق مع دول اخرى في
جميع انحاء العالم من اجل اداره دوليه لما
يحدث بالاضافه الى ذلك اتخذنا خطوات
لمحاوله تسهيل قدره الايرانيين على
التواصل في ما بينهم ومن ثم التواصل مع
العالم الخارجي حول ما يحدث في بلادهم حتى
نتمكن من تسليط الضوء الكافي على
المسؤولين عن ذلك ومحاسبته سنستمر في
القيام بهذه الاشياء من الرئيس الذي تحدث
بشكل مباشر للغايه وواضح وعاطفي حول هذا
الموضوع واكدا ان هذه الحكومه تقف الى
جانبه حقوق المتظاهرين السلميين وحقوق
المراه وتس في الدفايه عنتره بالانسانيه
وحقوق الناس في كل مكان وتتحدث علنا من
اجل حياه افضل وسنواصل القيام بذلك
والى الميلاد الامريكيه اللماسك الذي وجهت
اليه حمله الكترونيه بصفته ملكه للمطالبه
بايزاله حساب المرشد الايراني علي خامنه
على هذا موقع الاجتماعي والتي وصلت الى
اكثر من 100,000 توقيع حتى الان وذلك بعد
ان شارك اكثر من 62,000 شخص خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه في الحمله الالكترونيه التي تطالب
ملكه
حساب المرشد الايراني
الى ان عمليات القمع والقتل والتعليم
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
اجتماع الاستثنائي لوزاره الطاقه
الاوروبيين وفرنسا تعقد مؤتمرا دوليا
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في ملف تسليم
المواطنين مسعود ابو عجيل المتهم بصنع
قنبله هجوم لو كربلاء
العربيه
وقتل امريكيين كما سوء الى وجه الاعلان
وضعه الصحي واجاب بانه يعاني من امراض
الادويه وقال الدعاء ان الحكومه لن تطلب
معاقبته بالاعدام وبالتالي فان الحد
الاقصى للعقوبه سيكون السجن مدى الحياه
اتهم ابراهيم بوشناف مستشار الامن القومي
الليبي للولايات المتحده باخذ مسعود
بعجيله اسيرا لديها واشار بشنها فيلا
مضمونه اتفاقيه الثنائيه موقعه بين ليبيا
وامريكا عام 2008 بشان تفجير طائره
الوكربي تؤكد قبول الطرفين تسويه ماديه
وان المبالغ التي تم دفعها كامله
الاتفاقيه توضحوا حسب بوشنافه لا يجوز
بعدها فتح اي مطالبه جديده عن اي افعال
ارتكبت من الطرفين بحق الاخر قبل تاريخ 30
يونيو 2006 هذا هو نشره وسائل الاعلام
الامريكي صوره هي الاولى لمسؤول
الاستخبارات الليبيه السابقه مسعود
المريمي بعد اعتقاله من قبل السلطات
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
يعقد وزراء بطاقه الاوروبيون اليوم
في اوروبا
275 يورو في الساعه 1:00 لحد الاقصى للسعر
وقدره 275 يورو
تشهد العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس اليوم انعقاد
مؤتمر دولي يهدف الى جمع اموال لاعاده
اصلاح البناء التحتيه اوكرانيه المدمر
اضافه الى التاكيد على دعم فرنسا
لاوكرانيا حيث من المقرر ان يشارك وزير
الطاقه الاوكراني كرمان كالوتشيكو في
المؤتمر لطالب الامدادات والتمويل الذي
تحتاجه اوكرانيا خلال الشتاء وذلك بعد
تدمير 40% على الاقل من البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه خلال الشهرين الماضيين
مشاهدينا من باريس ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه حسين قنيبر اهلا بك يا حسين اذا
مؤتمراني في باريس احدهما ثنائي والاخرون
ماذا في تفاصيل الحسين
صباح الخير احمد بالفعل المؤتمر الدولي
اولا يبدا بعد دقائق قليله من الان
ويتراسه كل من الرئيس
شخصيا
ونظيره
الاوكرانيسكي عبر شاشه فيديو كما يحضر
رئيس الوزراء الاوكرانيا الدونيز
وستشارك في هذا المؤتمر الدولي حوالي 50
دوله تحديدا ثمان 48 دوله تشارك في هذا
المؤتمر بالاضافه الى 24 منظمه دوليه
تشارك دول الاتحاد الاوروبي وكذلك
الولايات المتحده وكندا والهند والسنجا
فورا والدول الخليج التي ستتمثل عبر
السفراء باستثناء قطر التي تتمثل عبر نائب
وزير هذا الحضور الخليجي له اهميه خاصه
كما قال مصدر دبلوماسي تانسي مشيرا الى ان
حضور ممثلي دول الخليجيه يعني يعتبروا
خروجا عن المشاركه الكلاسيكيه التي كانت
سابقا في هذا النوع من المؤتمرات تقتصر
على دول المعنيه مباشره بنزاعا ما المؤتمر
الدولي سيناقش الاحتياجات الملحه
للاوكرانيين وسبل اعاده تاهيل البنى
التحتيه المدنيه في قطاعات معينه خصوصا
الطاقه من تدفئه والكهرباء والمياه والنقل
والصحه والامدادات الغذائيه سيصال الى
التوافق حول اليه تنسيق مارينا لتسريع
تقديم المساعدات وتقاسم المهمات بين شركاء
وبعد انتهاء هذا المؤتمر الدولي بعد الظهر
في حدود الثانيه من بعد الظهر بالتوقيت
المحلي يبدا مؤتمر ثنائي اوكراني فرنسي في
مقر وزاره الاقتصاد والمال الفرنسيه
بمشاركه 500 شركه فرنسيه ستعرض خبراتها
وخدماتها لمساعدات الاقتصاد الاوكراني على
اعاده الانطلاق احمد طيب حسين يعني في ما
يتعلق بالمؤتمر الدولي ما الذي تعوي عليه
باريس لانجح هذا المؤتمر خاصه وان هناك
تباين اا كبيرا فيما يتعلق بدعم اوكرانيا
سواء على الصعيد الاوروبي او الصعيد
الدولي بشكل عام
نعم هناك تباينات كبيره اولا بين اوروبا
من جهه والولايات المتحده من جهه اخرى
وثانيا بين الدول الاوروبيه نفسها لا يمكن
مثلا مقارنه مواقف الدول مثل الموقف
الفرنسي بمواقف مثل موقف هنغاريا تعتبر ان
اوروبا لا يجب ان تكون معنيه الى هذا الحد
بمساعده اوكرانيا حتى ان المانيا نفسها
تختلف مع الفرنسيين في مسائل كثيره على
راسها المساله المتعلقه
ولكن دعني اشير الى ما قاله مصدر دبلوماسي
فرنسي اعترف بوجود تباينات مع الامريكيين
من جهه وضمن الاوروبيين انفسهم من جهه
ثانيه لكن هذا المصدر الدبلوماسي الفرنسي
قال ان المطلوب من هذا المؤتمر ان يبعث
برساله الى روسيا مفادها ان محاولاتها
وتغيير استراتيجيتها منذ اكتوبر تشرين اول
الماضي لناحيه التركيز على ضرب البنى
التحتيه المدنيه في اوكرانيا بهدف اضعاف
المقاومه الاكرانيه هذه الاستراتيجيه لن
تنفع
وستقابلها استراتيجيه اوروبيه تعيد تاهيل
البنى التحتيه المدنيه وتمكن الاوكرانيين
من الصمود اشاره اخيره الى ان فرنسا ستعلن
عن تقديم مبلغ
125 مليون يورو من بينها 49 مليون ستقدم
لاوكرانيا من الان وحتى نهايه هذا الشهر
وست 76 مليون تقدم من الان وحتى حلول شهر
اذار مارس من العام المقبل الاحمر
على هذه المؤتمرين شكرا لك من باريس كنت
معنا مراسل العربيه الحسين شكرا حسيني
مشاهدينا هذه صورنا مباشره من باريس حيث
ستستضيف وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كما
ذكرنا همم بعد قليل بحضور الرئيس الفرنسي
والرئيس الوزراء اوكرانيه
حول اوكرانيا
مشاهدينا يضم الينا المحلل السياسي ناصر
الزهيري اهلا ناصر معانا في هذه النشره
اذا هل سينجح وزراء الطاقه الاوروبي جول
في ايجاد الصيغه توافقيه فيما يتعلقوا
باسعال الغاز
لانه هناك معارضه من اكثر من 10 دول داخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي حول الصيغه المقترحه وهي
تحديد سقف لاسعار الغاز واليه الشراء
المشترك لانه هناك دول الرئيسيه مثل
ايطاليا والمانيا تقول بان هذه الانيه
تقود مبدا التدفقات بالنسبه لي الغاز الذي
يحتاجه الاوروبيه خاصه في فصل الشتاء
وايضا يضعف مبدا او اليه التفاضليه
بالنسبه للدول الاوروبيه في شراء الغاز من
الموردين الذين يعتبرون ايضا تحدث مثلا عن
النرويج والولايات المتحده ولذلك في
الصيغه الحاليه التي طرحتها المفوضيه
الاوروبيه الامر صعب ربما يكون هناك
تعديلات التوافقيه بين جميع الاطراف ويكون
هناك ايضا او يحتاج اوروبيين الى محادثات
مع حلفاء الولايات المتحده التي يبيعونها
الغاز الذين يبيعونها الغاز منهم النرويج
والولايات المتحده اذا استسمينا روسيا
ولذلك اعتقد بان القمر صعب في هذا التوقيت
الاعتماد على الرائع للغاز الروسي بين
دوله اخرى يعني مثلا معروف ان اييي برلين
او المانيا تستورد 55% من احتياجاتها من
روسيا اما فرنسا 7% فقط وهذه فجوه كبيره
بالتاكيد
صحيح بالتاكيد ولكن
ستريم
اثنين يعني اصبحت المشكله بالنسبه للغاز
الروسي بما نتحدث عن مبدا موردين الغاز في
الاتحاد
الروسي اكثر من 50% من دول الحرب
الاوكرانيه ولذلك الان نحن نتحدث عن
خلافات فيما يتعلق في حتى المواربين
الاساسيين الذين رفضوا بيع الاوروبيين
باسعار
اقل من اسعار السوق تتحدثون عن الولايات
المتحده التي طلبها الرئيس الفرنسي في
اكثر من مناسبه
بعدم رفع الاسعار وبيعها باربع اضاءات
مدابي
الشركات الامريكيه الداخليه ولذلك هذا ما
تعترض عليه الدول الاوروبيه نقطه روسيا
هذه نقطه اولى
الاتحاد اوروبي ومبدا الثقه بان هؤلاء
الموردين سيبقون يمدون الاتحاد الاوروبي
باصعد بالغاز حتى لو تم تحديد سقف ليس على
الغاز الذي يشتريه الاتحاد الاوروبيين
يطرح مبدا اخر وهو اليه الشراء كان كل
الدول الاوروبيه بنفس الاليه بنفس الاسعار
وهي ايضا لا تحظى بالثقه او موافقه جميع
الاعضاء شكرا لك من باريس على المحلل
السياسي ناصر زهير تحرس الناصر
مشاهدينا اكد وزير الطاقه الاوكراني
جيرمان غالوت شينكو ان على العالم اعاده
النظر في السلامه بعد سيطره روسيه على
اكبر محطه للطاقه النوويه في اوروبا الى
ان السيطره القوات الروسيه على محطه
تحول وغيرت مفاهيم الامن النووي لاوكرانيا
وزير الطاقه الاخرانيه اضافه ان سيطره
روسيا على المحطه دمر اي مظهرين بمظاهر
شبكه السلامه التي وفرتها اتفاقيات
البلدين او اتفاقيات البلدان الغربيه
والوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه لتطورات
الميدانيه الى المشاهدين حيث صرح مسؤول في
البنت كونج بانه روسيا تستخدم نتيجه
حضرت سرعات الفرنسيه مشاهدينا الادارات
الرسميه ومؤسساتها من خطر تلقيها طرودا
مفخخه كتلك التي استهدفت مؤخرا باحفلات
الاوكرانيه وهيئه رسميه في اسبانيا بحسب
ما افاده مصدر امريكي السفاره الاخرانيه
مشاهدينا في باريس كانت قد تلقت طرد
المماثلا حسب صحيفه
اعلن متحدث باسم الخارجيه انا بعثتها
دبلوماسيه اوكرانيه عديده في اوروبا
وكانت السلطات الاسبانيه اعلنت انها
اعترضت طرودا اخرى ممثله
وبين انعقاد القمه الامريكيه الافريقيه
اكد مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي في
البيت الابيضان ان الولايات المتحده
ستلتزم بتقديم 55 مليار دولار لافريقيا
على مدى السنوات الثلاث المقبله
بينما تتجه الانظار الى العاصمه الامريكيه
واشنطن حيث تعقد القمه الامريكيه
الافريقيه بحضور رؤساء وقاده 49 دوله على
مدى ثلاثه ايام
تستبقوا اداره الرئيس الامريكي الحدث
باعلان التزام الولايات المتحده بتقديم 55
مليار دولار لقاره سمراء على مدى سنوات
ثلاث المقبله
مستشار الامن القومي في البيت الابيض
على الطاوله مؤكدا ان بلاده ستعلن دعما
انضمام الاتحاد الافريقي الى مجموعه
العشرين خلالها
اشار ايضا الى ان ايضا سيعين ممثلا خاصه
لتنفيذ ما يخرج عن القمه هو ان بلاده لن
تفرض شروط خلالها لدعم اوكرانيا قمه تاتي
بعد قرابه ثمان سنوات من انعقاد القمه
الامريكيه الافريقيه الاولى والتي عقدت في
العمل 2014
وجرى خلالها مناقشه مبادرات في مجالات
الطاقه والخدمه الماليه وتغير المناخ
والامن الغذائي والرعايه الصحيه اللي تثير
تساؤلات حول ما اذا كانت امريكا تسعى
اتباع نهج جديد في القاره السمراء
والالتفات الى مصالحها هناك عبر اطلاق
تعاونات المشتركه ام ان هذا هو انضمام
متاخر الى مضمار سباق الجاري في افريقيا
ومنافسه كل من الصين وروسيا اللتين كانت
قد شقتها طريقهما فيها بالفعل
نشاطره مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
تنسيق بين واشنطن وصول وطوكيو لسد ثغرات
العقوبات على بيومها
وسط ايدانات دوليه لعمليه اعدام الناشطين
في ايران
تصفها بالتصعيد الخطير
المتهم الليبي بتصنيع قنبله لوربيه
تنسيق الامريكي ياباني كوري جنوبي غير
مسبوق لرد موحد على تهديدات كوريا
الشماليه النوويه
الارجنتين بقياده ميسي تواجه شجاعه
كرواتيا ونجمها مودريتش في نصف نهائي
مونديال قطر
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد اتفقت كل من
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان على تنسيق العقوبات بحق كوريا
الشماليه وسد الثغرات في نظام العقوبات
الدوليه عليها واوضح ممثل كوريا الجنوبيه
لشؤون السلام
الماضي
حمله اعلانيه جديده
الوسائط الاجتماعيه والذي كان منتشرا من
قبل
[موسيقى]
مصائب تويتر تهبط بردا وسلاما على منصه
تمبلر المنصه بشعرها الذي يشبه التويتر
كثيرا تحاول ان تقتنس الفرصه
الحياه في شرايينها من جديد
الشهر الماضي بدا تمبلر حمله اعلانيه
جديده لتشجيع المستخدمين على العوده الى
نظامه الذي كان شائعا من قبل في ظل
تغييرات المتوسطه يعاني منها الطائر
الازرق منذ ان سيطر عليه الى مصر في بدايه
عام 2007 تم اطلاقه منصه
السيسي
في تلك الفتره حيث وصل عدد مستخدمه وبعد
اسبوعين فقط من الاطلاق الى 75,000 مستخدم
كما سجل فيه لاحقا 75 الف مدور
حتى وصل عدد المسجلين الى مليونين تمبلر
منصه تدوين الاجتماعي تسمح لمستخدميها
بالتدوين على شكل نص او صوره او ملفات
فيديو او روابط او اقوال او محادثه او حتى
ملفات صوتيه
يستطيع المستخدمون في تمبلر متابعه باقي
المستخدمين فتظهر تحديثاتهم على حساباتهم
الخاصه كما يستطيعون تفضيل او اعاده ارسال
التحديثات في الموقع كما هي الحال مع
تويتر
تمبلر يبسط منصته مراحبا ومن جديد
بالمستخدمين محاولا كسب ثقتهم ومن ثم جذب
المعلمين مع العمل على سحب البساط من تحت
اقدام تويتر الذي يقدمه هو الاخر فرصه من
ذهب لمنصات التواصل الاجتماعي الاخرى
للعوده بل والمنافسه في خضم بحث
المستخدمين عن طرق جديده وسهله ومستقره
للتواصل
في اخبار المونديال تقام اليوم المباراه
الاولى من الدوري نصف نهائي بين ارجنتين
وكرواتيا بعد مفاجاه الاخيره باقصاء
المنتخب البرازيلي احد المرشحين للفوز
باللقب وفوز الارجنتين على هولندا يتقابل
في نصف النهائي الاول في البطوله فيما
يلتقي المنتخب المغربي مع نظيره الفرنسي
غدا في نفس الدور العربيه مشاهدينا التقت
في المغرب مجموعه من اصدقائي وجيران النجم
المغربيه يوسف النصيري في الحي الذي نشا
فيه في مدينه فاس نتابعه
لاعب كبير
الهداف التاريخي الفريق الوطني
اهداف تاريخ
العالم 2018
والحمد لله قدر يوصل العالميه
بفضل مجهودات ديالو الكبيره بالنسبه
اليوسف الناصري ماشي ماشي صاحبي ولا ولد
حومتي بل هو خايس صغير الاخ ديالي الصغير
لا النا عشت معه في المنزل نتاعوه شاركت
معهم طعام مع والدين مع مول العزيزه مع
ادريس مع اخوته كاملين بالنسبه ليوسف
النصيري هو واحد الفخر المدينه احنا عيد
الوطني
وحاله انتصارات واسود الاطلس جماهير
الوداد والرجاء الغريمين التقليديين في
الدار البيضاء وخففت الفرحه من حده
التنافر بين مشجع الناديين في ارجاء
المدينه بعد التاهل التاريخي لمنتخب
المغربي المربع الذهبي
نحن في وسط الدار البيضاء اكبر مدن المغرب
كيف وحدت الانجازات التاريخيه للمنتخب
المغربي
جماهير الرياضيه التي كانت منقسمه في
كازابلانكا الرجاء والوداد يتقاسمن احياء
وساحات المدينه
[موسيقى]
والسبب الملحمه التي يسيطرها اسود الاطلس
في بطوله كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
يعني شعب ودادي ورجاوي نقولوا مجموعين كنا
كنا نتسنا وغير نجاح ديال المغرب يعني
وفرحاني بنجاح دياله
من منطقتي باب مراكش اشتقنا ليحيى وامكنه
اخرى ضرب السلطان وساحه الصراخنه الميساجو
العام مو هو نفسه
نشوه التاهل التاريخي للربع النهائي الى
المربع الذهبي وهيمنه روح الوطني ومشاعر
الوحده
والاعتزازي في انتظار انتصار اخر استثنائي
في ما ارتفع سقف التطلعاته والطموحات
ممكن نقول لهم يزيدك من المستوى اللي
قاعدين فيه وان شاء الله يديه وان شاء
الله كاس العالم
في الدار البيضاء المعروفه بكونها يحضر
الوجهات الرئيسيه لسياح القادمين للمغرب
وعاصمتها الاقتصاديه اثر في بعض زوارها
ومن بينهم هذا السائح والسعودي
كل ما جاءت مباراه
يثبتوها الشعب التواد والتراحم ما بينهم
ولا فرح العارمه
وفي انتظار الاستحقاق القادم يبدو تالقوا
ممثلين المغرب ملهما بالنسبه لشبان هي
الاكثر كثافه سكانيه في المملكه خليل
الجنود العربيه الدار البيضاء
وفي الاستعداد لمباراه المنتخب المغربي
المنتظر في نصف نهائي لكاس العالم عبد
المالك ابرون رئيسه بعثه المنتخب المغربي
في كاس العالم خاصه برنامج الكاس بتصريح
حصري لنستمع اليه
من قام بتحضير المنتخب المغربي هو والد
الركراكي
ووليدتهما المنتخب الوطني
الاستاذ محمد فانه في ظرف وجيز استطاع انه
يكون توليفه مهمه رائعه جدا انسجن باهر
يعني تواصل خارق للعاده الحمد لله والشكر
لله كما قال سيدنا الحسن الثاني الله
يرحمه برحمته الله قال لا تستطيع نفسك
على راس الكتيبه الوطنيه على راس المنتخب
الوطني وعرفت يستمر الفرصه
هذا الايجاز كله حساب المواليد الرجاجي
والجميع الملكيه المغربيه لكره القدم
انه يبصم على بصمه همم كبيره جدا همم امام
الكره العالميه اليوم وايد الرجراجيله شان
في الكره العالميه الصبح عنده شان كبير
واللي عرفه تصبحوا لعابه عالمين رغم انهم
تلعبوا في الفرق عالميه ولا يهبونا اي
فريق فهمتي حق الانجازات جدول الانجاز
ونتمنى ان احنا عندنا طموح كبير بس نتخطى
وتدور النصف النهائي
ونلعبوا على الكاس العالم ان شاء الله
يسال منتخبان الارجنتيني والكرواتي لخطف
الاولى بطاقات الدور النهائي عندما
يلتقيان اليوم في ملعب لوسيل بالعاصمه
الدوحه
في العاده نحن لا نركز على لاعب واحد فقط
وانما ننظر الى الفريق ككل المنتخب
الارجنتيني ويملك الكثير من اللاعبين
الرائعين وعلينا التعامل معهم جميعا سنقدم
افضل اداء لنا ونلعب باقصى جهد
لدينامه
في الملعب انه مثال للكثيرين ليس فقط بسبب
مهارات كلاعب ولكن لاسلوكه ايضا وهو ما
ينطبق على ليفاندوفسكي فهو ايضا لاعبون
عظيم ما يحب كره القدم يريد ان يرى هؤلاء
الرجال في الملعب
يواصل المنتخب المغربي استعداداته لمواجهه
منتخب فرنسا قبل اللقاء المرتقي بينهما في
نصف نهائي البطوله
في الجانب الفرنسي تغيب لاعب
المدافع اوباميكانو عن مران المنتخب
الاستعدادات لمواجهه المغرب
منتخب المغرب
قدم الاتحاد الاسباني لكره القدم
الويستلاف وانت مدربه جديده لمنتخب
اسبانيا خلفا لويس انريكي المقال بعد خيبه
الاقصاء من كاس العالم
فاز الاهلي على ضيفه الاتحاد السكندري
بثلاثه اهداف دولارات في لقاء المؤجل على
الجوله الرابعه من الدوري المصري
مشاهدينا من القاهره
الى قمه كرويه هامه في هذه النسخه من كاس
العالم بين كرواتيا والارجنتين هل سينجحوا
ميسي ورفاقه في استعاده امجاد عام 86
الحقيقه ان ميسي يرى هذه النسخه هي بارقه
الامل الاخيره له من اجل حصد لقب يعني
يضعه ذنبا الى جنب مع مارادونا الذي حصد
هذه اللقب في عام سته 86 ااا المنتخب
الارجنتيني ربما كما قال ديلتش يشعر
بالضغط اكثر ااا لكن المحاربون اا محاربي
التانجو وكما يطلق عليهم اثبتوا كفاءه
كبيره عدو من بعيد بعد خساره امام صقور
السعوديه قدموا اداء مبهرا لديهم اكثر من
لاعب جيد بخلاف ميسي وعلى راسهم حارس
المرمى الرائع المليان ومارتينيز همم فريق
همم ايضا يبتسم بالجماعيه الشديده همم هذا
الفريق همم قادر على ان يحسم المواجهه لكن
المنتخب الكرواتي ايضا يشبه الثعبان
الناعم فريق يستطيع ان يصل بكل منافسين
الى ركلات الترجيح ثم يحسم الامر كما
حسبهم على اليابان كما حس انه مع البرازيل
مع فارق المدرسهتين
ان المنتخب الكرواتي لديه الكثير من
الاوراق القادمه على حسب المنتخب الكرواتي
بالتاكيد يعني فريق لا يستحم به وصوله الى
هذا الدور نصف نهائي ليس مصادفه همم هل
الروح القتاليه التي يتمتع بها الفريق هي
التي سترجع ربما ترجع كفته امام الارجنتين
في تقديرك
الحقيقه ان ان التاريخ يؤكد انديه كامله
بين الفريقين همم الفريقان تواجهها خمس
مرات فازك لهما همم مرتين وتعادل في
مباراه حتى في التسجيل المنتخب الكرواتي
همم سجل تسعه اهداف او سبعه اهداف مقابل
خمسه اهداف للمنتخب همم الارجنتيني همم في
كاس العالم فازت همم الارجنتين مره واحد
صفر وفي وفي
النسخه الاخيره في 2018 فازت كرواتيا 3-0
اذا هذا يؤكد انديه كبيره وكامله بين
الفريقين لديهما همم قائدين منهمين همم
بنتكلم عن مودريتش وليونيل ميسي همم
كلاهما قادر على ان يدوخ همم الدوافع احمد
في ناس زملائي اعتذر لك جدا يعني هذا سامح
به الوقت شكرا
احمد جلال الناقد الرياضيه مشاهدينا نلتقي
الى باريس وهو مؤتمر الدوري لدعم اوكرانيا
او كلمه رئيس الفرنسيه مانويل ماكرون
هناك دول اوروبيه
قديمه
[موسيقى]
هذا المؤتمر اليوم ياتي
الدعم المقدم الاوكرانيا
وهذا الاجتماع
[موسيقى]
فمدي ادي الفوم
سياده الرئيس وزراء اليوم مساء اليوم في
فرنسا
لبحثي المساعدات الفرنسيه
للمساعدات الفرنسيه العاجله لاوكرانيا
اوكرانيا باشراف من الوزير الخارج
او تاخذه
هنا الى ان الفا و800 من المجتمعات من
اعضاء المجتمع المدني قدموا مساعدات للشعب
الاوكراني
فقط وانما على كل شرائح المجتمع الفرنسيه
وانا اشكرهم جميعا
هذا المؤتمر
شفت فيها
دق دق
انت اليوم انت الان موجود في باريس بحضور
ضيوف دوليين
وهؤلاء الحاضرون
الحرب ايضا من اجل اوكرانيا اقول انه ان
ال- ال-
انهم يدافعون عن سياده اوكرانيا يجتمعون
هنا اليوم في باريس لدعم سياده اوكرانيا
نقطه البسه
شكرا
سياده الرئيس شكرا
مشاهدينا اعلن مدعي عام في نيويورك
اوقفت بطلب من القضاء الامريكي الرئيس
التنفيذي السابق لمنظمه لمصر
بعد الانهيار المفاجئ لشركته وقال المدعي
العام داميان ويليامز في تغريده النهار
تويتر ان سلطه في جزر البهاماس اوقفت
سامويل باك مان فريد استنادا الى لائحه
اتهام مختومه صادره عن منطقه نيويورك
الجنوبيه
العناوين مشاهدينا
وصف ادانات دوليه لعمليات اعدام الناشطين
في ايران واتش تصفها بالتفصيل الخطير
المتهم الليبي بتصنيع يظهر امام القضاء
الامريكي وتاكيدات بانه لن يواجه الاعداء
تنسيق الامريكي ياباني
الارجنتين بقياده ميسي تواجه شجاع تذكرتها
ونجميها مدهش في نصف نهائي مونديال قطر
نهايه